Charlie Kirk and the Turning Point
machine would not exist if it was not
for how generous Donald Trump was to us
throughout the years Patrick I was 24
years old sitting in the Oval Office as
a non-college graduate getting invited
on Air Force One
if I if I would forget that I mean I
would be the most ungrateful
short-sighted person to turn my back on
the man who believed in me when I was
not nearly as you know let's just say
successful or popular as I am today and
so I I have an obligation to him in the
best possible way I don't want to be one
of those people that benefits and turns
the back and I also have something to
say about that a lot of people talk
about Trump's negatives I hear about all
the time but he has some virtues some
great virtues he works relentlessly I've
never seen someone with as much energy
as him he loves the country he's
amazingly patriotic he's very creative
and honestly he was a fabulous president